happy Wednesday reject nation I'm Greg
Alba John we're gonna watch the trailer
for a Halloween here we go here we go
Universal they're always so kinda every
reaction you know anyone does be
monetized so easily everyone will agree
who does reactions guys listen over at
our patreon we do full-length TV show
reactions and weekly Q&A s there's a
whole bunch of other [ __ ] over there but
I just wanted to say thank you to
everyone who's been following us at our
patreon you guys are the bomb and if you
don't follow us you're still okay in my
book
either way it's like a second channel
over there just wanted to shout it out
even though this video is monetized
definitely you guys know why I'm really
shining out the patreon anyway I'm a
little under the weather but it 8:00 in
the morning let's film this
Michael's just full of bass
forty years ago on Halloween night
Michael Myers murdered three people
after that recognize he was sent back to
the institution in captivity
oh noes poor old lady
[Music]
I have prayed every night that he would
escape Cadell did you do that for
yeah
so I can kill him it's gonna be fun like
plain sight the bus crashed my wife's
escaped we return to have his home
there's a reason we were supposed to be
afraid of this really cool
[Music]
happy Halloween Michael
hater doesn't like that looks really
cool yeah you know you like the for that
first 30 to 40 seconds you get a good
hint of what the actual style of the
movie will be and more of its tone and
pacing I think it's interesting that you
know Michael Myers is known as sneak up
on people all the time and here you get
a watch and sneak up on people and like
a really fluid motion which is much more
impressive yeah like some crazy handheld
stuff you just watching him go and like
I'm out in the neighborhood I'm gonna go
into his vs. backyard girl who's
hammerwatch a walk inside this woman
some eater with the hammer yeah I'm
gonna take that knife and I'm gonna walk
her in this person some sneak up behind
her while she's looking at the window
yeah really delivering on what they kept
saying beforehand which is like going
back to the spirit Elam cuz yeah and the
old Halloween Michael is kind of like a
shark and you are just kind of following
a guy right like it does have a snuffy
quality yeah just kind of following this
guy around and yeah having these long
shots is so much more tense than just
editing him right into a closet yeah you
know or whatever and I love that one
sequence where he's in the reflection of
the window and the woman comes up to
check it and he's behind her in the
house like yeah that was a cool
supernatural visual flair for this the
trailer giveaway that the cops gonna die
you know maybe it's a mislead maybe he's
gonna walk right through that door right
as Michael goes who I think the only
thing annoying about this trailer it's a
nitpick it's sliding it's very Halloween
and horror movie issues anytime he
appears that why does it take place on
Halloween now this is the bass drop
thing yeah he's like an easy effect to
get that jump scare those kids but I'm
wondering if because the music in this
movie I imagine will be a subtle music
or I'd be fascinated if there was really
no music and servant scenes where
normally these movies would have music
like the moments where he's stalking in
the walk
I mean it's like it's easy to call upon
the Halloween music that we hear
whenever he's talking however I feel
like it would be really unique to like
have no music at all well I mean you're
not gonna get your wish because John
Carpenter's doing do you think but like
I feel like I mean it's certain scene
but you could because I feel like there
are decent amount of his movies that
have pretty minimal scores and stuff
like that and he's a guy who seems like
he can appreciate that kind of thing so
you never know and call me karate or
call me crazy
Jamie Lee Curtis is my he's just weird I
feel like she's way hotter here than she
was in the first hall and she's like 40
years older but personality never at
that giant gray mop on her it's like
True Lies she's hot yeah that's not the
only movie I was like Oh time she gets
together with a JC here I'm like you
know very attractive Jamie Lee Curtis is
truly Cougar going and hey I mean like
that I liked also that this trailer is
basically just about Michael and Laurie
because there are other characters too I
mean she's got like a daughter and a
granddaughter and stuff but mostly I
mean this does look kind of Ripley ish
if there was something I would kind of
predict of how this movie would play out
the only thing I would predict is in the
camerawork like there's an obvious
structure Bethany Paul Greengrass no not
that's what I mean I feel like by the
time you get closer to the finale I
imagine they'll probably get a lot more
handheld a little bit more whereas the
first half will be a lot smoother and
it's camera work and then by the end it
starts to get a lot more gnarly I got
that scene towards them what towards the
end of this trailer has to be close to
the end of the movie I imagine yeah
everything's falling apart everyone's
dying the KERS like he's trying to save
everyone
yeah the build-up to the big holiday
kills yeah that'll probably
be a show-stopping number but yeah she
looks like full-on Sarah Connor Ripley
in this movie yeah no I mean I feel like
that's kind of a new trend that we're
doing is like let's revisit something
old and get an actress from the original
be badass in this one the other thing
that was cool about this is like they
got I think his name is Nick Castle one
of the original guys who played the
shape in the original movie and like you
kind of tell he's like an older dude the
way he's walking around yeah which I
also just like as knowing that I don't
know if you pick it out if you didn't
know it but I really appreciated the
motion that he brought to it here cuz
you can kind of tell you know well
alright man this movie looks pretty
sweet right when I was getting pretty
cool pretty confident about it really I
didn't love the poster is why they they
put out a post yesterday I was like oh
it was gang you cynical no not in a big
way it wasn't a big deal it's just like
I don't know I'm trying to create
tension which is not in me don't judge
me
alright hey you can subscribe to the
reject nation click or ring or it's hit
to click the notification about strike
the bell know why people say told the
bell and check us out patreon don't like
TV show reactions weekly Q&A z' would
love to have specifically you become a
patronage act today